sur un sujet aussi intime plein
d'humanité mais attendez c'est moi la
main 30 chaque fois qu'on écrit
là-dessus ça explique peut-être le fait
que nous soyons pas totalement clair
mais encore que je vais y revenir et
parce que c'est un sujet extrêmement
complexe et le CCSE n'est pas là pour
dire ce qu'il faut faire ou ne pas faire
il est là pour une boussole à la fois
peut-être un peu pour vous je l'espère
et surtout pour nos citoyens et c'est un
élément important alors sur sur la fin
de vie elle-même écoutez nous nous
sommes saisis et j'ai bien compris je
suis assez sensible à ce message de il y
a beaucoup de monde qui a travaillé sur
sur la fin de vie et so what alors
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on retient je
vous rappelle quand même l'historique de
tout ça le CCNE alors que nous étions
encore dans la crise covid en juin 2021
se s'auto saisit du sujet de réflexion
autour de la fin de vie pourquoi parce
qu'il y avait eu déjà deux tentatives de
la part d'un certain nombre de vos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale pour
voter à la petite semaine une loi sur la
fin de vie et je n'étais pas d'accord
sur ce fait là c'était un sujet qui
était suffisamment important pour qu'on
prenne le temps de prendre le temps sur
un sujet citoyen qui est majeur pour
nous tous qu'on aille dans une direction
ou qu'on aille vers l'autre et c'est un
sujet qui est d'une très grande
fragilité je vous rappelle les deux mots
clés de notre avis c'est autonomie et
solidarité
autonomie qui est une valeur éthique
fondamentale avec la notion de liberté
individuelle et solidarité qui engage
finalement une vision plus collective de
s'occuper des plus fragiles et c'est
notre c'est un grand principe éthique et
Dieu sait qu'on est dans un élément de
fragilité quand on est en fin de vie
quel qu'en soit son milieu
et donc la vie du CCE comprend quatre
parties je vais bien les résumer pour
essayer de construire ma pensée entre
guillemets là-dessus une première partie
qui fait qui dit très clairement que la
loi cléonetti n'est pas suffisamment
connue ni appliqué
ce qui pose d'ailleurs le problème de
l'évaluation des lois en France et de la
complexité des politiques publiques une
deuxième partie qui dit qu'on peut faire
mieux sur les soins palliatifs quand
j'entends qu'en France on n'a pas bougé
sur les soins palliatifs c'est faux moi
vous n'imaginez pas pour un vieux
médecin comme moi qui a connu la période
SIDA on avait rien on avait rien de rien
bon et il y a maintenant dans l'ensemble
des départements des lits de soins
palliatifs il y a des départements qui
n'ont pas d'unité de service de soins
palliatifs mais il y a des dans tous les
départements français y compris dans les
territoires ultramarins vous avez des
lits ou des unités mobiles de soins
palliatifs donc on a on a beaucoup
progressé quand on met on peut encore
mieux faire il manque encore il y a des
besoins quantitatifs et qualitatifs qui
sont importants la culture palliative
n'est pas suffisamment rentrée autour de
à la fois de nos médecins de nos
soignants en général en dehors bien sûr
des des spécialistes de soins palliatifs
bon le troisième point
a été de dire et si on avait tous ces
moyens
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un certain nombre
de situations
en particulier où le pronostic vital et
réservé à moyen terme par moyen terme
quelques semaines quelques mois quelques
exemples des maladies neurogénaires des
génératives de type slam mais pas que ou
des cinquième ligne ou des sixième ligne
de chimiothérapie ou là où il y a une
forme je dirais de d'obstination
déraisonnable à certains moments et so
what de présenter une nouvelle ligne
enfin bon et où là au nom de la dignité
de l'autonomie est-ce que certaines
personnes qui le souhaitent mais ce
n'est pas absolument pas du tout une
obligation évidemment c'est les
personnes c'est les citoyens qui le
souhaitent peuvent-ils avoir accès à une
aide médicale à mourir et le CCNE répond
oui et donc on ouvre dans une certaine
mesure la porte sur le suicide assisté
et non sur le tanasis je peux pas être
plus clair que que qu'aujourd'hui sur
dans des conditions précises qui sont à
définir et on vous passe le bébé pour
définir les conditions entre guillemets
et puis le dernier point j'insiste
là-dessus le CCNE dans son avis et qui
est sorti en septembre
2022 demande qu'on prenne le temps de
prendre le temps et qui a un grand débat
national avec une convention citoyenne
avant que ça revienne vers vous au
niveau du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale et somme toute sur ce point-là
quand vous me disiez l'impact ou la
relation par rapport aux politiques oui
là il y a une il y a une fonction
politique au sens je dirais citoyenne du
socine qui rentre dans la politique de
la cité et qui dit oui c'est un sujet
suffisamment important pour qu'on prenne
le temps et de façon à vous débrouiller
une forme de terrain avant que vous
fassiez ce qu'est la vraie construction
de la loi